So let's get started training
a logistic classifier.
A logistic classifier is what's
called the linear classifier.
It takes the input, for example,
the pixels in an image, and
applies a linear function to them
to generate its predictions.
A linear function is just
a giant matrix multiply.
It take all the inputs as a big vector,
that will denote X, and multiplies
them with a matrix to generate its
predictions, one per output class.
Throughout, we'll denote the inputs
by X, the weights by W, and
the biased term by b.
The weights of the matrix and the bias,
is where the machine learning comes in.
We're going to train that model.
That means we're going to try to
find the values for the weights and
bias, which are good at
performing those predictions.
How are we going to use the scores
to perform the classification?
Well, let's recap our task.
Each image, that we have as an input can
have one and only one possible label.
So, we're going to turn
the scores into probabilities.
We're going to want the probability of
the correct class to be very close to
one and the probability for
every other class to be close to zero.
The way to turn scores
into probabilities is to
use a softmax function,
which I'll denote here by S.
This is what it looks like.
But beyond the formula,
what's important to know about it
is that it can take any kind of scores
and turn them into proper probabilities.
Proper probabilities, sum to 1,
and they will be large
when the scores are large and small when
the scores are comparatively smaller.
Scores in the context of logistic
regression are often also called logits.